I'll turn to the story.
So the first problem,
as I mentioned,
is a complexity problem.
Things are just too complicated to get a
handle on and that actually has serious
consequences because what happens to
everyone eventually is that their lives
become so complicated that they die.
So and that and that and many terrible
things can happen to you on the way to
dying as well that are
complex complexity related,
right?
You can develop a serious illness
that you can't get a handle on.
You can hit a,
uh,
what would you call an impasse in your
relationship that you cannot get past and
see?
No way out of that happens
to people quite frequently.
People who are suicidal,
for example,
they often feel like they've
been backed into a corner,
that they have no options,
they have no good options,
no matter which way they turn.
There's something terrible to face
and they can't see any way out of it.
And sometimes that's more true than you'd
like to think because we also tend to
like to think that people's problems
are primarily psychological,
but they're not not.
That's one thing you learned quite
rapidly as a clinician is that most of the
time people don't come to you
because they have mental illness.
They come to you because they have
a complexity management problem.
Their lives have got out of hand on
them and they don't know how to get them
back under control.
And so all sorts of things can do that.
And then of course that can
make you anxious or depressed.
It can trigger all sorts of illnesses,
but the fundamental problem is still
that things have got beyond you and that
actually has a psychophysiological
costs that isn't merely psychological.
You have a limited
amount of capacity from,
from,
from a resource perspective to
deal with emergent complexity.
You just,
it's just not enough of you.
you'll,
you'll exhaust your psychophysiological
resources if you get into a situation
that's too complex.
Well that's what this,
that's what the idea of chaos represents.
It represents that underlying complexity
that can manifest itself at any time.
And it can manifest itself.
For example,
if you're,
if you wake up in the
morning and you know,
you feel an ache of some sort and
perhaps it's nothing and you ignore it,
but it gets worse and you end up going
to the hospital and you find out perhaps
for example,
that you have pancreatic cancer and
you're going to live for six months.
And that's the end of that.
And so it's,
it's,
it's at that moment that you break through
the thin ice that everyone walks on
and you see what's underneath and
what's underneath is the ineradicable
complexity of life.
And that's chaos.
That's now it's taken people a long,
long time to get a grip
on this conceptuals,
what would you call it?
Conceptual Schema.
And,
and human beings have done it mostly
with image and story before they've been
able to do it in any articulated manner.
And so there are a set of images
that represent this underlying chaos.
And one of them is the
dragon of chaos that,
that precisely,
that that's the dragon that
the hero goes out to confront.
That's the symbol of the unknown.
It's the thing that lurks underneath.
It's the thing that also guards
treasured because in the unknown there's
possibility also the,
the,
the water that was there,
we talked about in the
Mesopotamian creation myth,
the water that's there at the beginning,
um,
both the salt and the fresh water
is often a symbol of pre cosmo,
Garnett chaos.
Um,
often people have dreams.
For example,
some of you have had this dream,
I suspect you'll dream that you're
in a house that you know well,
and all of a sudden you discover a new
room or a set of new rooms or maybe a set
of rooms in the basement
and often the rooms are,
are,
are not well organized
and they're full of water.
Those are very common things.
And what that means is that you've
broken through the constraints of your
conscious self understanding
to a new domain of,
of possibility,
but a new domain that needs
a tremendous amount of work.
It says,
well,
here's the new part of you,
but it's not well developed.
Theirs,
theirs,
it's flooded.
It's flooded with chaos essentially.
And it's water.
I think partly because chaos is not
only what you fall into when you're not
expecting it,
but it's also the unknown
that you confront forthrightly
and generate new things
out of.
And water is a symbol of life,
especially in the desert.
And of course,
water life is dependent on water,
and so water's a natural symbol to utilize
when you're talking about something
that's life giving,
but also potentially deadly,
cause a little bit of water.
Well that's a drink,
but a lot of water,
that's a shipwreck.